wer will den cdu vorsitz die partei
wartet auf klare worte der möglichen
kandidaten ende der quarantäne corona
verdacht bei deutschen china rückkehrern
hat sich nicht bestätigt
erste medaille für deutsches team denise
herrmann holt silber bei der biathlon-wm
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend hier kommt ihr
nachrichtenüberblick vom sonntag mit
viel wintersport und rudi cerne hallo
guten abend wie geht es weiter mit der
cdu
kommende woche will die vorsitzende
kramp karrenbauer gespräche mit
möglichen nachfolgern führen und nicht
nur im politischen berlin hört man
derzeit genau hin wer sich mit welcher
äußerung in stellung bringt heute
meldete sich nrw-regierungschef armin
laschet zu wort mit kritik an der
europapolitik der kanzlerin
frank buchwald berichtet armin laschet
ist ein vorsichtiger man kritik an der
kanzlerin von ihm kaum zu erwarten heute
aber in münchen wagt laschet ganz
behutsam eine distanzierung der
koalitionsvertrag nicht der jamaika der
jetzige ist überschrieben medien für
europa davon hat man die letzten zwei
jahre so viel nicht gemerkt laschet gilt
als aussichtsreicher kandidat für den
chefsessel im adenauer-haus ebenso wie
entspannt der gesundheitsminister heute
im bericht aus berlin
auch er aber bleibt vage wir spüren hier
gleichzeitig sowie die gesellschaft auch
ein stück polarisiert ist ist das
natürlich auch in die partei hinein
getragen auch das sehen wir in den
letzten tagen umso wichtiger ist jetzt
dass wir das vernünftig miteinander
machen schritt für schritt in berlin
direkt interview ralph brinkhaus der
chef der unions fraktion selbst kein
kandidat lässt sich nicht aus der
reserve naja um eine breite mehrheit in
der bevölkerung da wird man kämpfen
müssen und das wird auch genau der
maßstab für unsere entscheidung sein
wer dort auch erfolgreich sein wird die
spd koalitionspartner in berlin will der
cdu zeit lassen die arbeit der
bundesregierung habe dürfe nicht unter
dem machtkampf leiden wir brauchen
stabilität in der bundesregierung dann
muss die arbeit weitergehen und die
instabilität der union darf nicht zu
einer instabilität der bundesregierung
werden cdu-chefin kramp-karrenbauer will
nächste woche mit möglichen nachfolgern
reden alles weitere erst nach der
hamburg wahl am nächsten sonntag der
druck aber wächst von tag zu tag
am rande der sicherheitskonferenz in
münchen war auch der bürgerkrieg in
libyen thema dort engagiert sich
deutschland ja für eine lösung
aussenminister maß
hatte erst vor kurzem die mächte nach
berlin gebeten die in libyen mit waffen
und kämpfern für ihre eigenen interessen
kämpfen und sie auf einen waffen startet
erfolglos jetzt der neue versuch in
münchen anne gellinek am letzten tag der
sicherheitskonferenz nimmt die
diplomatie einen neuen anlauf zur lösung
des libyen-konflikts die aussenminister
der länder die vor vier wochen in berlin
zusammen saßen ziehen in münchen bilanz
sie ist niederschmetternd
der vereinbarte waffenstillstand ist bis
zu 150 mal gebrochen worden das
waffenembargo wird dauernd unterlaufen
wichtig wird aber seien transparenz
herzustellen und dafür zu sorgen dass
diejenigen die noch weiterhin die
absicht haben dieses embargo zu brechen
davon ausgehen müssen dass sie dabei
nicht unerkannt davon kommen schon
morgen sollen die europäischen
außenminister darüber beraten wie die eu
bei der durchsetzung des waffenembargos
helfen könnte eine überwachung durch die
luft ist wahrscheinlich eine neuauflage
der eu mittelmeer mission sofia er nicht
besonders ungarn und österreich fürchten
dass die schiffe wieder migranten in
seenot aufnehmen müssten
am ende der konferenz ist die
sprachlosigkeit zwischen den usa und
europa deutlicher als je zuvor
doch es gibt hoffnung sagt der chef der
münchner tagung
ich würde mal sagen ich bin etwas
weniger pessimistisch als vor drei tagen
ich habe den eindruck die europäische
union bekennt sich mit der frage zu
befassen müssen wir vielleicht in der
tat die sprache der macht lernen
die mächtigen sind abgereist die
konflikte sind geblieben
die sicherheitskonferenz hat die lage
der welt offenbart lösen aber kann sie
sie nicht
nach bundesweiten razzien gegen eine
mutmaßliche rechtsextreme terrorzelle
haben die ermittler offenbar neue
erkenntnisse wie der spiegel berichtet
soll der mutmaßliche anführer der gruppe
von den sicherheitsbehörden als
gefährder geführt worden seien
außerdem wurde ein treffen von
verdächtigen personen observiert zwölf
mitglieder der gruppe sitzen inzwischen
in untersuchungshaft
dämpfer für tesla das
oberverwaltungsgericht berlin
brandenburg hat die rodungsarbeiten für
die geplante autofabrik erstmal gestoppt
zunächst müsse über eine beschwerde von
umweltschützern entschieden werden
tesla hatte mit den rodungsarbeiten in
grünheide schon begonnen hier will der
konzern künftig bis zu 500.000 autos pro
jahr bauen zum corona virus und seinen
folgen
zwei wochen lang waren mehr als 120
china rückkehrer in einer kaserne in
rheinland pfalz in quarantäne
heute durften sie gesund nach hause
auf dem kreuzfahrtschiff diamond
princess sind inzwischen mehr als 350
menschen infiziert für 100 andere
passagiere gab es dagegen gute
nachrichten an seinem stern das ende
einer kreuzfahrt quarantäne zumindest
für einige hundert mehrere länder
darunter die usa lassen ihre bürger
jetzt abholen
sie dürfen die diamond princess im hafen
von yokohama verlassen müssen aber zu
hause wohl wieder in quarantäne für den
rest der passagiere heißt es weiter hier
ausharren mindestens bis mittwoch sagt
uns ein deutscher urlauber an bord ich
persönlich rechnen weil ich 75 bin und b
in einer innenkabine wohn und die in den
kabinen werden auf jeden fall bevorzugt
der tag der freiheit in germersheim in
der südpfalz kam er heute schon die 120
china rückkehrer alle gesund dürfen nach
hause nach 14 nicht immer leichten tagen
in der kaserne also dass man doch wenn
man raus ging irgendwie wirklich immer
nur um die kaserne und wann kann man
jeden grashalm also dass das fühlt sich
schon ein bisschen komisch an einer zeit
an sophie kam wie die anderen aushub aus
dem zentrum der virus krise wo die
zahlen der infizierten und der toten
noch immer weiter steigen
starkregen hochwasser und orkanböen
selbst für die sturmerprobten briten
kommt es wieder ganz dick sturm dennis
setzte in den letzten stunden ganze
ortschaften wie hier in wales unter
wasser am flughafen heathrow hatten
viele piloten probleme mit gefährlichen
turbulenzen
hunderte flüge wurden gestrichen vor der
südostküste wurden bei rauer see zwei
tote geborgen
ja und jetzt zum wintersport mit rudi
cerne und ein schöner erfolg für die
deutschen im schnee strahlende gesichter
bei deutschlands biathletinnen in
antholz denise herrmann holt bei der wm
in der südtirol-arena die ersehnte erste
medaille in der verfolgung über zehn
kilometer sichert sich die
titelverteidigerinnen dank einer starken
laufleistung den zweiten platz denise
herrmann und das breite grinsen die 31
jährige sichtlich erleichtert nach der
ersten medaille für das deutsche team
bei dieser wm silber
jetzt wirklich ein gar nicht so einfach
ertrag ich war schon sehr aufgeregt weil
ich wusste es ist alles drin
die verfolgungs weltmeisterin von 2009
10 vergibt beim letzten schießen ihre
chancen auf gold muss noch einmal in die
strafrunde
auf der strecke attackiert sie 300 meter
vor dem ziel die zweiplatzierte
norwegerinnen mathe als böse land und
geht vorbei
gold für dorothea wierer aus italien auf
rang drei hinter denise herrmann als
böse land aus norwegen bei den männern
bester deutscher auf rang fünf
verfolgungs weltmeister wird
überraschend emilia ja klar aus
frankreich und zum abschluss der rodel
weltmeisterschaften in sotschi hat
deutschland in der team staffel gold
gewonnen und zwar glücklich da russland
als favorit des touchpad verfehlt und
disqualifiziert wird julia taubitz
johannes ludwig und toni eggert/sascha
benecken siegen vor lettland und den usa
in der fußball bundesliga gewinnt bayern
münchen beim ersten fc köln deutlich mit
4 zu 1 in der tabelle die bayern wieder
auf platz 1 einen punkt vor leipzig köln
bleibt vierzehnter und der deutsche
serienmeister berlin und favorit hat
nach 2016 wieder das pokalfinale im
volleyball gewonnen die mannschaft setzt
sich mit 13 0 gegen düren durch und
triumphierte zum fünften mal im pokal
dagegen ein hochklassiger krimi im
finale der frauen mit 3 zu 2 kann sich
der dresdner sc in schwarz gegen den mtv
stuttgart durchsetzen und wiederholt
damit den pokalsieg von vor vier jahren
für dresden ist es der sechste
pokal-triumph und gefeiert wird
wahrscheinlich jetzt noch das war dank
und wir haben auch das wetter morgen in
der mitte und im südwesten viele wolken
und häufig regen im norden und im
südosten einzelne schauer bei 8 bis 14
grad nur an der küste stürmisch das war
es von uns in aller kürze marietta
slomka und das heute journal um 21.45
und hier ist morgen christian sievers
für sie da
danke dass sie dabei waren einen schönen
abend noch